previously on TVs is seriously not to be
the evil step tab if you put on a puffy
white shirt and declare your love for a
16 year old you're gonna be swinging
from the flagpole and your puffy white
Underpants where the woman has orders
for this shirt based on me wearing it on
TV
[Music]
what looks like cider takes it it's fat
I drank fat I feel like there are other
senses that could have been utilized to
clear this up before resorting to
ingestion I don't even drink water
without smelling it first but I love a
smelly cat Ross later says it even has
chicken bits floating in there this is
not a mistake a human would make yeah I
know I did that two minutes ago this is
not a mistake do humans would make will
be ready well it takes us two minutes to
get dressed
even in sitcom logic two minutes seems
on the optimistic side of donning a full
tux unless of course you have one from
The Naked Gun I'm really starting to
notice all the interesting artwork and
pieces Monica and Rachel have around
their apartment and one of my favorites
is the piece of what appears to be a man
about the donkey punch a dog that's a
fact
multiple choice time glass of fat ones a
what I drank daily when I was a teenager
because my best friend took me into
thinking it would give me the libido and
girth of John Holmes beat my college
girlfriend's nickname for me during that
short spell where I had an addiction to
the Superman ice cream at baskin-robbins
see what I used as part of my Clayface
costume in third grade and in turn
ruined the plumbing of my house for the
next month or D my junior high nickname
that I mistakenly thought people were
spelling PHA t.j Mir put in New York
City fountain water in his mouth as a
hundred percent of sin you know how many
people urinate in there it's not even
the homeless like every kid that can't
find a porta potty in Central Park has
contributed here hang on I thought this
episode was titled the one where no
one's ready Ross and Phoebe are clearly
ready to go and it only takes her a
second to correct the future huh mistake
so that's a full third of this group and
this title is a lie you know what it
doesn't matter for once I agree with
Melman here one of the biggest problems
with situation comedies is that they so
quickly run out of the situations that
they resort to this guy gets mad at
another guy because he took his seat
that isn't special in any way and they
have to leave in 15 minutes anyway
nonsense good thing the comedy part
works because this situation part
certainly doesn't does this look like
something the girlfriend of a
paleontologist would wear I don't know
you might be the first one Pheebs would
be feet asta cat TV since I wrote a
little song today it's called get up
weirdly Chandler rips off Harry Nilsson
hit song but also predates Russian dolls
theme so I guess we'll call this a wash
still a sin though Oh cinemasins fans
when a video drops on a Saturday there's
no way this launch resulted in this much
dip on Phoebe's dress I'm not even sure
you could launch that much hummus off a
Frida
if you try that's like pornstar levels
of hummus right there should I call him
back
57% of this series is Ross Joey and
Chandler saying no in unison I'm so
comfortable me too I think I might be a
little too the ability for Joey to pop a
half-chub on Chandler in this shorter
time frame is both impressive and
offensive we have minutes but when Ross
out of the apartment he said they had 26
minutes of take-out 43 seconds for the
intro and they should still have 21
minutes to get ready and yes I know it's
close but this show is choosing to use a
real time plot line and I'm a dick so
sinewave stain just moments ago look
like this now it's faded to this maybe
you don't need to do anything about it
just let it be and then nothing will
eventually take it past the PI remember
answering machines and how after telling
you how many messages you had they gave
you a space to crack a joke and let the
last I down before continuing to play
your messages for you good times think
about getting your answering machine
messages remotely through a landline
back in the days that they didn't sound
like a professional voice actor recorded
them in a pristine studio played back on
a Dolby quality sound system which we
have to leave for in exactly 12 minutes
the fact of the spotl episode takes
place in real time and in the same room
it's pretty impressive
it's like Hitchcock's wrote except Jimmy
Stewart is a sniffling paleontologist
and instead of murder it's a hummus
stain damn it I thought I was taking a
sin off for this but when I put it like
that so in the words of a mmm get out of
my chair dillhole
everyone knows the actual a a melon
quote once get out of my chair douche
pickle but the real sin here is this
unclaimed full glass of orange juice
that's been sitting here this entire
time and no one will ever even notice
whose is it
where did it come from how could
somebody just leave it there you've
abandoned your old guy I'm sorry I
thought it looked pretty Ross that was a
Halloween costume unless you would like
me to go to this thing as Little Bo Peep
you know this episode is filled with
enough great jokes and comedic
performances that something is obvious
and silly is Ross mistaking a Little Bo
Peep costume for an evening gown should
have been left on the writers room floor
and yes it gets us to a Chandler has the
inflatable sheep joke but also not that
funny where's my underwear
come on come on wake his underwear he
took my essence now wait a second here
when Chandler went over there to get
changed he had no idea Joey was gonna
take the chair cushions so we're going
to need a little more explanation as to
why you'd have Joey's jockeys I don't
care if they match I don't care if they
make your ankles or your knees or your
earlobes look fat okay no no just do it
hey you remember how much we love these
characters that are nice and friendly
and compassionate and all that stuff
that each episode it's all over
exhibit a if you're going to go with
this monstrous cover-up shouldn't you at
least have the stain covered up welcomer
NICUs so I could do the thing or just in
the New York Knicks because they're the
Knicks but instead I'm going to send it
they're even called the Knicks which is
short for knickerbockers which was a
popular fashion trend from the early
settlers where pants had really baggy
knees it's basically like waking up in
20 to 19 and there's a professional team
called the Los Angeles yoga pants is it
wrong that I was totally aroused by that
yes I mean no you're a product of your
time I mean you're making a joke but one
that's maybe cheap at the expense of
women know anything I mean goddamn this
show is hard to reconcile with the
current climate sometimes isn't it maybe
if I wasn't going commando
okay but to be fair that only affects
the bottom item of clothing and even so
washing machines are thing right what
can I do to show you how how much how
much I want you to be there you could
drink the fat aha I knew that was gonna
be check-offs fat as soon as Joey pulled
it out of the fridge and let it set out
on the table the entire episode I think
you should drink the fat and I think
this is the point I realized I didn't
want these two to actually be together
because he's a needy codependent stalker
and she's a cruel and immature
narcissist but you all just continue on
with your bras and Rachel's shipping
like these two wouldn't destroy each
other within the first five years of
marriage
Rich's previous battle world battle and
all right they got water orange juice
purple stuff
oh yeah oh yeah all right I just have to
do one thing really quickly what gets
out hummus
he's got nothing you got nothing
she must have that caller ID thing you
should get that when you're friends with
Sydney you die
well these friends don't have to Sydney
you're gonna drink the fat